ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show coming at you from the fall
we're in the fall we're in the season of
apple picking and pumpkin picking and
halloween
and other things covered in civil war
and blah blah blah but those take a
backseat to the fall
the smells of the fall the crisp autumn
it's funny to see companies market
things with the fall
even though the world is falling apart
but everyone's still into autumn right
you know
they're like it's the it's our last fall
but they're like but it's still the fall
get a pumpkin spice latte and throw it
in a cup
it's still the fall the crisp
smell in the air is from the fires that
are burning
uh homes in oregon or
the fires as people burn down the
courthouses
but that's okay it's the fall get a
pumpkin muffin
sit on the porch and watch the bloodshed
it's autumn
it's the best season digital school is
back
zoom school is back it's the fall
get your pumpkin spice latte and head on
out it's
spooky it's halloween time
it's gonna be it's a spooktacular
i love watching you know because we we
can't we got to go back to some type of
normalcy
even though things are just batshit
crazy so everybody's just like hey it's
the fault you know what that means
you know what's back pumpkin cheesecake
who wants some pumpkin cheesecake you're
like oh gosh all right
why not come out because it's like
quarantine's
ending but it's also not and they're
re-locking down but they're not
and nobody even knows anymore and
they're re-locking down parts of new
york but but
some of them aren't and it's like
they're locking down the hot spots and
you know i'm sure that that's not going
to be a problem
like you're locking down the hospice
like you're locking down spots of people
that just are are
there's more covert cases right right so
now what if there's more covet cases in
an area
that's um generally a specific
race
uh oh because that's what they do in new
york with the jews
hasidic jews are over it orthodox jews
are over it
shout out to the sedum shout out to they
see them they're over it yep
they they're done they want to be done
with it
they want to walk around williamsburg
with those hats that i really enjoy the
big furry hats
and they're done and now they're trying
and now we're gonna
they got a lot damned i'm a little
uncomfortable with locking the jews down
am i wrong this is the progressive thing
is to lock the jews down
that's the progressive ideology now
i don't want to lock anyone i don't care
what's going on if there's coven
somewhere stay out of there
don't go these hospitals better be busy
as [ __ ]
every nurse that i know is off
so if these hospitals are busy i swear
to god
they they better be like busy busy
it better not be like one wing is busy
and then everything else is not
it better be every floor of the hospital
has got to be packed if we're going to
shut down again i mean it's
i'm not being unreasonable here if we're
gonna start locking down
specific areas which is uh troubling to
me
a little troublesome we gotta go in and
lock down williams but wait wait why
this doesn't seem to be the move
[Music]
come on they're like well the
thanksgiving holiday that is one
lockdown i'm
lock down thanksgiving i want a
quarantine that starts thanksgiving and
ends the next day
everyone in their house no traveling now
this hurts me and this is painful for me
many people who watch the show who have
listened to the show
and who've been a part of me and
benjamin's lives know
how much i love my family
how important they are to me and how
much of my success i attribute to them
and their great parenting and their
overall general support of me
you know their occasional emails and
texts i it's so the the support system
i've had
has been just a solid foundation
and it is sad to me it is sad
that i will not be able to see them this
year for thanksgiving
and and they say tim oh we haven't gone
to thanksgiving five years now that is
true
but what and and the reason i've been
doing that is because i've been
i've been weaning myself off like a drug
i've been weaning myself off my family
so that this year i'm prepared to go
cold turkey
and not see any of them for the holidays
sorry
i'm sorry but of all the ways you can
get coven imagine getting it from your
aunt
cheryl go [ __ ] a stranger
go buy tickets to one of my comedy shows
on my website right
now go to a trump rally they seem fun
do whatever you want go to a coveted
[ __ ] fest
go to a kissing party go to a halloween
event
go to a glory hall those do seem rather
safe but whatever you do
don't get covered because you ended up
listening to your aunt
cheryl talk about uh how great kamala
harris is
for an hour in your in your uncle's
house while he sits there and drinks
himself to death in his chair
that is not what we need you don't want
to be breathing heavy because you saw
you
by the way imagine if you could get aids
from your family
at least you got aids it was fun
for most people getting aids was fun
that's the problem with covid no one's
having any
fun getting it there are people with
aids that are like i don't regret that
tensum
i had where i was just everywhere
in which way a dick was coming i'd even
know where they were coming
they were filling every orifice of my
body and it was a lot of fun i couldn't
walk for three weeks and yes i have
aids but it was fun covert is like how
did you get covered i took a bus to work
that's not fun is it nor is it going to
your family's thanksgiving dinner
and by the way and i've said this before
in the show if you don't have
children the holidays are not for you if
you are a single couple
and you have not procreated and you're
older if you're younger if you're ben's
benjamin's age him and his lovely wife
they're young enough they're gonna have
kids there's
there's oil in the tank so to speak but
if you're older and you don't have any
children and you're just going to go
and sit with uh your family and inflict
them
with all of your observations and
thoughts
about the body politic stay the [ __ ]
home
get some chinese food cocoon yourself in
a bed
and watch ncis or one of those shows
that are the most popular on tv
that i've never seen and don't know what
they are and wouldn't i don't understand
i just mark harmon
everybody's getting court-martialed it's
about the navy i don't know but
everybody what go watch the big bang
theory
and eat general tao's chick and you
don't have to go and get everybody sick
at [ __ ] thanksgiving
he hears about it two days later they'll
be like aunt kathleen was a super
spreader we're all gonna die
[Music]
thanksgiving's an event for
people and uh
and it's not like christmas there's no
gifts
so it's just a nice dinner
it's a big dinner and it's there's
something nice about it everyone can
celebrate it in america
everyone can celebrate it uh it's not
racial there's no religious connotation
you can go in
you watch little football you eat a
little turkey whatever most people i
don't know if antifa
celebrates thanksgiving i imagine many
of them are forced to
many of their parents drag them to the
somebody's house and go you have to
before you blow up the bank you have to
go to antanas
she wants to see you she hasn't seen you
since you're a child and he's like
fine where are my fireworks
you get them back after the meal
you get them you get your fire you get
your fireworks back after the meal
i imagine the proud boys love
thanksgiving yeah they're really
annoying about it
they're like cool it's football you're
like no no we don't want it
no we don't want to do that let's throw
the ball around
come on what are you what are you trans
you're like hey hey relax
hey relax what's wrong with you i'm in a
men's club
okay what
proud boy antique and thanksgiving
that'd be a fun video
we did a fun video uh uh about uh
costumes and halloween and i dressed up
like a uh
uh we i we at the end i dressed up like
those two mccloskeys who were they what
are their names
the mccloskeys the famous viral photo
of two people uh standing outside of
their property with weapons
and by the way i have no problem with
them doing that i don't know why other
they
they look fun there they are
now what was going on you had a protest
going through their neighborhood
let's see this is a wealthy area of st
louis
mark and patricia mccloskey the central
west end couple who confronted
protesters
june 28 with a rifle and a gun in mayor
lydia
krusten's neighborhood have been charged
with unlawful use of a weapon slash
flourishing the unlawful use of a weapon
charge is a felony and can carry up to
four years in prison
gardner said in a statement that is
illegal to wave weapons in a threatening
manner at those participating in a
non-violent protest
and we while we are fortunate the
situation did not escalate into deadly
force
this type of conduct is unacceptable in
saint louis
well i guess the protest was peaceful
but the mccloskeys
were saying hey just in case the protest
gets a little wild
so they're on their way to the mayor's
house the protesters were on the way to
the mayor's house and mccloskey's
what a great couple forget the way you
feel about them politically
they're just fun any couple by the way
can you get the picture go down a little
bit okay go down to the left go over
there
right there this one yeah get that that
to me blow that up
this to me is is how that is how
you make a marriage work right there
just people that share values
what has he got what is that an ar he
looks like he is an ar yeah and she's
got
look what is that baby 380 what she got
she's got a little p90 i don't know
some and they're out there looking at
the protesters and they got a big ass
house
and they got a lot of [ __ ] money and
there's people on their way to the
mayor's house and they're probably
chanting eat the rich and the mccloskeys
are going if you're gonna eat
us we're gonna eat you
and i don't know anything about i don't
know how peaceful the protest was
maybe it's maybe it was uh girl scouts
down the street selling cookies
but we've seen a few of these protests
and they do get a little
fun and people's property does get
damaged
quite often so i think i guess the
mccloskeys
patricia mccloskey patty or as i call it
pat
pat mccloskey and her husband
watkins told reporters the pistol pat
mcclaskey used
was only a prop form uh i'm sorry a prop
from a federal trial that the couple
used in a case both of them were
attorneys
great and they were on a private street
the protesters a source familiar with
the investigation
told five on your side the police did
not find any ammunition at the
mccloskey's home
and that the rifle was not loaded when
they seized it well then maybe they're
pretty smart
yeah maybe they went out with the dummy
prop weapons i don't know
in any event i dressed up like the
mccloskeys at the end of the video and
it was a fun
little halloween video we're doing
another one of course last year was the
famous epstein
temple video hard to top that we had a
costume designer design
a temple a jeffrey epstein's temple
which was it a music room
was it a fitness center was it a uh
a church for human sacrifice we don't
know
we don't know but there i am right here
the epstein temple was a great halloween
costume we drove around
for two days looking for those white
tights god that was a nightmare remember
that oh yeah
and we just said and and they said what
kind of you need white tights the good
thing about l.a is they can't really
question you because
i could they could be like why do you
need this and i go what do you mean
i wear what i want they're like right i
would just go to lane bryant the fat
woman store in la and they would be
lovely to me yes
i'm going i'm but i'm i am megan mccain
they'd go good
they don't give a shits la they know
better than open their mouth
show me the [ __ ] tights now
show me something that makes me look
svelt and they would have to do it
so the lane bryant ladies would just
walk us around lane bryant and i would
try on
women's clothes and then the women in
lane bryant would be like eh it doesn't
work
everyone's fat anyway no one elaine
bryant's really
paying attention to anyone else
everybody's just like
you know nobody's thrilled to be in lane
bryan they were kind of
they were nice kind the staff was kind
the other women in there like they were
helping me try on things they don't care
they're like we're rolling it together
this guy's a cross-dresser
you know they're all fat theater chicks
it's great
i miss lane brian i'm sad and close i
wish i could shop at lane bryan all the
goddamn time
if they open lane brian up again i'm
back in there with those kind fat
theater chicks that are nice they just
want to hang out with gay guys and eat
mozzarella sticks
and they hope no one at the after every
after every show there's a wrap party
or whatever you know uh you know after
tech rehearsal dress rehearsal
everybody goes to the diner and then
there's the fat theater chicks sit there
and they just don't want anyone to
notice how many mozzarella sticks
they've had
and they do that by continually calling
attention to
they'll be like oh my god have i had
have you had have you had have i
i think i've had two have i had two and
you're like we know you're gonna
you just eat it cheryl eat it
but i like them at lane brian i wish i
could be [ __ ] back there being
treated with some goddamn respect
but i can't i should show up to
thanksgiving
by the way this should be the only
thanksgiving i consent to going to
because it doesn't happen
last year my family did like a zoom
dumb thing or they did a zoom easter oh
man
not last year but you know a few months
ago right right they did a zoom
easter and nobody knows what's going on
half the people in my family are drug
addicts they're like they just see them
staring they're like
i'm like are they okay do they need help
they're into just they're living in
their own filth we see that
their zoom background is just a mattress
on the floor
[Music]
they're mid overdose trying to get the
words happy easter out of their mouth
foaming at the mouth i'm like who needs
this get me out of here i didn't even go
into it
somebody screenshot it and said it to me
i said i will not be participating
by the way listen to this my stepmother
sends me a thing today sends me a link
goes
my mother's turning 80. can you make her
a video
what do you want me to wish your happy
birthday as epstein's temple
what do you want me to do so i they you
know these things now where it's like
somebody's birthday everybody has to
make a video and send it to them yes
hi thinking of you wish we could be
there
so i just you know i have my glasses on
i'm like
hey dorothea we love you
stay strong i said stay strong
like she's the woman has cancer it's
just your birthday
my black glasses on i'm like dorothea i
love you stay strong
better days ahead this is what i say i
don't even realize what i'm saying ago
stay like literally she got diagnosed
with a disease i'm just wishing her
happy birthday she's actually in great
health
probably in much better health than me
imagine that a fat guy telling you to
stay strong
like i'm i look like i'm literally dead
and i'm like dorothea stay strong
better days ahead i go better days ahead
and then i go
stay safe and then i swear to god i go
like this i go
see on the other end and then i finally
say happy birthday
it's the most cryptic and disturbing
message
i didn't know what to say and then i'm
like done and then i just hit send
because i didn't want to edit it
so literally the whole video is hey
dorothea
stay strong better days ahead i'll see
you on the other end
out and then probably cuts to somebody
who's like happy birthday
we love you and it's lit it's literally
sandwiched in between two peppy happy
birthdays
it's like happy birthday happy birthday
to you and then they cut to me and i'm
like
dorothea stay strong when i make it i'll
send word for you stay
safe better days ahead just in black
glasses and then it cuts to somebody
being like
happy birth how old are you now
i look like i'm in a safe house i'm just
laying on
my bed like this on top hey
happy birthday i can barely breathe i
think i've covered i'm like
happy birthday i smoked too many
cigarettes last night i'm like happy
birthday
stay safe better days ahead
hope to see you on the other side
it's just the darkest if you're wearing
sunglasses i'm wearing black sunglasses
because i was outside
in the pool and then i get this message
like hey you gotta
you gotta wish this woman happy birthday
because she gives a [ __ ]
they asked my cut they asked a couple of
my cousins were on heroin they're on
smack
they've met her twice when when you have
a divorced family nobody knows who
anyone else is
what if they're gonna ask her for money
hi
happy birthday dorothea i've run into
some hard times and i
i want to let you know if i give you my
uh bank account number is there any way
you can send a wire here could you send
a wire here please i'm suffering
and i need [ __ ] help
that's great how great would it be next
time somebody should do one of those
video birthday measures
do something like that you know
especially if you don't know the person
you're kind of annoyed by it
i know this woman i love her she's a
phenomenal woman she lived in la i like
anyone who's lived in london her and her
husband are great
her husband's great because he
doesn't give a [ __ ] like he's arguing
for the supreme court
he's rude he belittles people he ruins
holidays and there's no archetype of
person that i like
more than that he did a thing
where he would bring he had this game
that would play after the holidays
where he would bring a thing that nobody
knew what it was
and you would pass it around and you got
to ask him a question about it
you're like was this you was this a tool
was this
used whatever and was this used in food
production
and you would ask him and you'd get to
go around the table and then somebody
would guess
what it was and they would move on this
game got
so competitive that he was banned from
doing it
because it got so because he would
he would be so specific about the
answers he would give like he was in a
courtroom
like if somebody would say was this in
food production he'd be like
no and then you'd find out it kind of
was but it was involved in the
harvesting as a like he was so specific
that people get pissed off and people go
hey man
i [ __ ] kind of said that didn't i and
he'd be like well you didn't
and he'd be like words matter and what
you did
and they would start fighting so he was
banned from doing this like
they had to come and by the way he
wasn't doing it at his own parties
he was bringing it in our family keep he
was just bringing it to art like people
he
didn't know that well and getting and it
got fiercely competitive
and and his name is henry i think he's
great and they would go like they would
be like um
[Music]
he'd say at the end of the night he'd be
like do you want to play the game and
everyone's like oh let's go play henry's
game
and then like 30 to 40 minutes in it had
gone around five times
nobody had gotten it and he'd refused
he'd be like
send it around again and it would just
be this little weird pipe
thing or and he always brought three or
four of them we'd only get to like one
of them
because also a lot of people in my
family [ __ ] so they have no idea
they have no idea they'd hold up like
this little
thing like a little lever thing you know
and they'd be like
did you find it in outer space and he'd
be like no
i'm like we're gonna be here for the
rest of the night unless you ask some
good questions
you know but they're all drunk and
idiots i have lawyers in my family who
are like not lawyers
i have people with law degrees my aunt
has a law degree
doesn't practice they've set up in the
basement a fake
law you want to talk about fake business
a fake desk
where she thinks she's practicing law
and there's nothing she's nothing's
happening
she's a pretend attorney in the basement
of the house
this is the tragedy of the irish no one
tells her that she's not
practicing law she's never seen a
courtroom she
sits she's worked at a few law firms
they keep throwing her out because she's
a problem
and so she sits downstairs and gets wine
drunk
and pretends to do law i don't even know
what that entails
there's like files on the desk she's got
phones she said when she goes we got to
put a few phone lines in for the
business
what bit the business but this is so
these are the people who are asking the
questions
of this really smart guy and he's a
fiercely liberal guy but
very smart tough to get in an argument
with him was like a cuban orphan or
something laudable life story he's like
one of those guys who like
he's a dick but he's earned the right to
be a dick because he's so [ __ ] smart
and he's really lived a hell of a life
right but he used to just throw everyone
into a rage with that game
but if you have to record one of these
videos you gotta just you know when
when it's you know when you do it when
you hit record you gotta go
hey jocelyn happy birthday times are not
good
i know you and frank are not doing well
either but i'd really like some help
so i'm asking i know it's your birthday
but i'm asking you for help
so for the love of god please give me a
call
i haven't heard from you in months send
something
the kids are going to bed hungry
like something like that because then by
the way it would cut right after that
too
happy birthday just like it's fun i
think it's rude to ask people for video
messages
just assume people kind of love you
which is what a family is a family is a
bunch of people who
kind of love each other i don't want to
see anyone
die that's
the the standard of love in most
families
yeah i don't want to see anyone get
demolished in a
car wreck but what else
that's the standard of love in most
family yes i would be very upset
when i say very upset i would be
bothered
let's let's take it down i would be
if one of my family members was mangled
in iraq
you know what i mean like i would be i
would not
i would feel bad for the other people
involved
and and i would say that's not good
i would call benjamin and i go that's
not good
but then we'd start talking about
sponsors and ads quickly because
you move on you move on from these
things i bet people are asking me to
do birthday videos i haven't seen these
people in six months we're done already
if you don't see people in the flesh
this is the problem if we go through the
holidays this year and you don't see
anybody
you're kind of done you're out you're
not you don't go back
next year if you're out for a year it's
hard to go back now obviously
you can go back many of you will go back
to your week
but if you've gone the full year and
you're gonna do holidays on your own and
you're gonna realize
that you can do that most people don't
think they can do
a holiday on their own i've gone out to
dinner with people
my mother didn't like my father's family
because they all used to drink and she
would instead take pills
so they she didn't like that she didn't
like
you know she didn't like that they were
drinking all the time and she just
wanted to take suit of fed in the diner
hats off to mom and she would go off
thanksgiving by herself at 3 p.m at a
diner in long island they'd do a nice
job
they'd do a good job it's tragic either
way
if you're sitting next to some drunk
who's gargling some problems she has
with another family member from 20 years
ago or if you're sitting alone at a
diner eating cranberry sauce
all peeled up
whichever way you cut the turkey it's a
[ __ ] day
so you don't have to you see what i'm
getting at here folks
make choices live by the choices
ladies and gentlemen we're not selling
enough blue chew please buy the dick
pill
we are selling in uh well with all the
other products some
maybe our fan just have hard dicks or
maybe they don't have sex and don't need
a pill
but like i've said many times in the
past you don't have to have sex you can
enjoy this pill you can take it wake up
look at it and go right back to sleep
it's nice just to see it perked up
blue chew is great it is we're talking
about great sex
all night long hard dick it's the first
chewable with the same fda approved
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
it's made in the usa
it's prescribed online by licensed
physicians so you don't have to go to a
doctor or wait in line
it's even cheaper than a pharmacy and
they prepare and ship it right to you
in a discreet package no awkwardness and
you don't need to leave the house
how cool is that so cool you should be
impressing the people you have uh
intercourse with and
um
you know i think this is the way to do
it
it is really really good to take a pill
that makes something work better
that is why pills have existed for
like they say millennia but i don't
think they have existed for millennia
what was the earliest pill
see what was the first pill
what was just type what was the first
pill we're gonna go on a list
1890. 1890
1898 heroin is introduced
first thought to be non-addicting so
heroin was the first thing that came out
i guess it was a pill yeah heroin was
the first one
and then a year later aspirin isn't it
amazing that the best one
was the first one
have they made literally no advancements
they first came out with h
well we're not saying do that we're
saying blue
b-l-u-e chu
c-h-e-w dot com promo code td to try it
free
blue true is the better cheaper choice
we thank them for sponsoring the podcast
remember when you support our sponsors
you help make this podcast possible so
please be sure to use our promo code td
at bluechew.com
okay everybody needs privacy
security peace of mind how do you get it
online expressvpn
expressvpn lets you change your online
locations you can control where you want
sites to think you're located
open the app select a location tap one
button to connect and refresh the page
to access
thousands of new shows slash movies
choose from almost 100 different
countries
watch studio gabil films anime on uk
netflix
watch anime on japanese netflix watch
doctor who on uk netflix
see more examples in top right corner oh
sorry
this works with anything this works
it's behind the scenes why would you
choose
this over the other vpn why there's no
buffering or lag you could stream in hd
with no problem
it's compatible with all your devices
phones laptops media consoles smart tvs
and more not only does it let you change
your location
it also encrypts your data and lets you
surf the web safely and anonymously and
by the way it's a great way
to support the tim dillon show it really
is if you support the advertisers
you're supporting the product the
content that we bring you
expressvpn.com tim dillon to get an
extra three months of expressvpn free
that's
three months 90 days of free service i
don't know where else you're getting
that [ __ ] deal
expressvpn.com tim dillon this is a
really good
vpn the quality is phenomenal ben uses
it
and he will attest to it i don't use i
don't have a computer i don't
really participate i have a phone and
then ben just
produces my life not only the show for
out to launch i'll go
look at that and he'll type in something
like ah
you know and sometimes it makes sense
like last night i was like what is this
what is the sonoran desert owl in banasa
he goes it's horned and i go oh yeah
yeah
but ben uses it he's he's the one that's
online he's surfing the web he knows the
deal
you gotta have one if you're not using
one i don't know what you're doing
at this point you gotta have a vpn how
are you gonna watch cuties
go to expressvpn.com tim dillon
to get three months free and i believe
that that is a great deal
that is a good deal donald trump is
moonwalking
he seems uh ebullient
he seems the polls are not good
but the polls weren't good in 2016 but
the polls
might the national polls have biden at a
nine point lead that's probably what
they had
hillary at pennsylvania's got biden up
florida's got biden up
michigan's got biden up
democrats have taken an early lead in
voting
here's the way i feel about this
election because many people are asking
me the way i feel about this election
okay
this is the way i feel about this
election we're at a point now
in this country where imagine the comp
the country is a corporation
half the people in the corporation are
convinced that the ceo is trying to kill
them
now whether that is true or not it's
becoming a very tough company to run
do you understand and the ceo
is tweeting out occasionally like maybe
i'll kill you
and you're going hey
this seems unnecessarily incendiary
does it not and the other guy that might
want to run the company
is the guy that sniffs everyone's wife's
uh
stiletto heels and is asleep
and then one guy is tweeting i'm gonna i
may kill
everyone lol but i won't wink wink
and then the other guy's like asleep and
dead
and those are the choices of who's gonna
run this failing
corporate and by the way it's a company
where we make things that nobody wants
anymore
we make pogs we're a company that makes
po remember pogs
remember those pogs yes
yes and slammers and spinning it was a
major
thing when i was a kid nobody wants them
and they were major they were collect
this is before pokemon
before any of that people remember pogs
america as a company right now
manufactures pogs
it's just that's the election
trump has not done a great job at
leading the company
he hasn't leading the company is not
all about the
ideas of the person which trump a lot of
them i don't know how many ideas
he has that are doable
or that he cares about trying to do
but it's also about like what about just
the day-to-day
psyche of an environment have you ever
worked in an office
and then the person who's leading the
company
hot like there was a guy rest assault
named mike mchugh
used to run a company i worked for the
guy was was a built
chubby irish guy you felt good
when you went to work at this mortgage
company because it was a legit
company on long island and he had
started it out of college
and he was like a respectable guy that
you wanted to respect you
and he just
acted the way a ceo should act
that's the way he acted right i didn't
know him
i didn't have that many dealings with
him but let's just imagine that that
the what i observed was a guy who's i
when they're like that's the guy runs
the company went
right right he didn't get drunk at the
christmas party
threatened to kill the staff he didn't
say that the other mortgage companies
should go to hell
you know like it was just it was a level
of decorum
that he had and everybody goes that
doesn't matter well it does matter if
you don't want to live in an insane
asylum
i don't care what this guy tweets but
yeah this is the thing california's
going to hell vote trump new york
joining hell voltron
you know i said on twitter the president
shouldn't be doing this and everybody
got mad at me they're like
well he's right you know and it's like
it doesn't matter
whether he's right or not and by the way
the country is going to hell so
he could just list all 50. go down
the list all 50. and that's not even his
fault
i don't know that he's helping but when
i said that people got mad at me like
whoa
bro i'm like the president it should
just may it's maybe not a good idea to
say that
states are going to hell because maybe
our enemies and the people who wish to
do us harm
might feel that we're a bit fractured
they might go what's going on over there
he goes new york has gone to hell he
goes illinois has no place to go sad
isn't it vote trump
this is this is the reasoning he's
giving
if you don't want to go to hell vote for
me
he's a lot of fun if he goes
it'll be but it's it's becoming
you know how do you are you that
invested in this
that you want to deal with the whining
and the yelling and screaming and the
nonsense
and and if it was all ridiculous like if
he wasn't
pouring any fuel on this fire which
which he is
you would understand it you'd be like
hey they're [ __ ] nuts
and i think the other side is bad to the
bone bad
the only reason that i think it might be
just my him losing my take the foot off
the gas
is because i think kamala harris is
going to be the president
and then eventually it's just going to
be obama too
and nothing is going to get done the
country's going to be destroyed
it's not going to matter anyway but
it will be somewhat livable during that
period it won't be
nearly as trump's not turning it around
he's not turning around i i don't know
what i who i have to tell this to
he's not turning it around okay maybe he
wants to
maybe let's say let's say
that for example during his years as a
uh you know philandering billionaire he
was actually thinking about the american
worker
and now he's finally got the chance to
prove that
the force is let's say that which i
don't believe but let's say that
the forces and the mechani he just can't
get anything done he's too
volatile um kamala harris is going to
come in
and i don't know what happens but i'd
really like to go back to
apathy let's go back to
let's return to apple no
no no
we want to be activists forever no you
don't
where were you during obama you were
doing that you were in brooklyn
you were in in these cities in these
rapidly gentrifying cities and many of
you were on stage doing comedy with
funny hats and canes and
you were dressed up like flappers in the
20s so you didn't give a [ __ ]
you just want to not go you want to go
back you want to go
to a place where you cannot you don't
have to give a [ __ ] anymore and by the
way
i want you to go there too i want you to
go there quickly
so i don't even care anymore i'll let
kamala elect beyonce
just shut the [ __ ] up what will make you
happy
nothing has ever changed what will do it
for you go
swim in a [ __ ] lake what will do it
for you people
when will you [ __ ] realize it's not
up to them
it's up to you you do something you like
i don't know what to tell you for the
love of god
but you it's all the dudes the
president's coming
we win you lose you're wasting your
lives
talking about this horseshit but
whatever keep doing it
so that's where i am at this election i
mean if trump wins again i'm gonna wake
up god trump's in again
if by to come on the win i go yeah there
it again i'm just gonna look out my
window and and hopefully it's all not
burning and if it is
i'll get in my car and drive away
that's how i feel about dealing if i can
or i'll be taken out of that car
and beaten to death in the street
but either way that's how i feel about
the election this war you're all
fighting isn't real it's on your
computers it's not an
actual war yes
i think you should get health insurance
i thought bernie sanders would have been
an interesting guy
to elect why he's outside of the system
and i don't know that bernie would have
been able to get anything done that he
wanted to get done
but giving people health care giving
people
a certain safety sense of security
so that they don't have to [ __ ] go
bankrupt when they get sick
it's as good a reason to pay taxes as i
can think of
it's better than bombing pakistani
weddings
for a terror war that is pretend
remember that that's pretend that's
another thing that's pretend
the fake terror war it shows all the
pretend this is a school play for
billionaires
and you people get invested in it all
the time so you don't have anything else
to do you're bored
get a hobby the great ray cumps has it
all the time get out hobby
learn how to master tennis i don't know
it's not my business
but i just want i want this election to
you know what i want to win
i want apathy to win
let's go back to that because you p you
you know stand up at a great point when
they took the stand up they're like
why don't you care anymore he's like
remembered when i cared and it did
nothing
right yeah so you people carings
may be making it worse it actually might
be making it worse
yes uh oh tim what you're rolling over
you're uh
saying that the elites uh should just be
uh guys i
you know i don't know what you think
you're doing
i don't know what effect you think
you're having between
i'm twins young twins
i don't know what they're gonna do yes
should women get abortions yes
is this [ __ ] or amy uh coney island hot
dog whatever her name is
is she gonna come in here and take start
yeah you're putting babies back in the
plus i don't know
i hope not i don't think it's gonna
happen
roe v wade hasn't been overturned since
1965. are they gonna make it harder to
get abortion i
maybe i don't i hope not are they gonna
reverse gay marriage i hope not
is it possible sure i think these
decisions would go to the states the
majority of the states would have them i
think it's
the [ __ ] up social conservatism [ __ ]
i'm not in for any of that but i'm not
in for any of it
i'm not in for any of it the supreme
court also for the most part these
social issues
that everybody talks about that obscures
the fact that what the supreme court
really does is protect the interests of
multinational corporations
that's what they really do but you don't
hear about those decisions
because everybody's talking about the
great debate about the
should a baby be able to transition in
the womb and it's like
yeah it's an interesting question but
also how about the company that's giving
you cancer and killing you
what are they allowed to do well they're
allowed to do anything and they damn
well please
the supreme court's also doing that [ __ ]
can you get politics out of your goddamn
heads for a minute
and enjoy it can you enjoy the descent
enjoy it
remember when
you had a party and you couldn't clean
up the next day
and you heard the doors of your parents
car
shut there was a moment of sheer
terror followed by a moment of almost
immediate acceptance we're caught
done then you just started worrying
about what was it going to be
a grounding who knows maybe they had fun
on their trip
maybe they'd be lenient but after that
moment of sheer terror you were like
you looked around at the house and you
knew it was so bad
that it wasn't one or two things you
could grab there was so much [ __ ]
there they knew what was happening
they're they're gonna get you
and you just had to kind of release
yourself and go hey man
sorry we had a party that's what you
have to tell your children
we had a party for 50 years we did it on
cheap credit
uh we did it by going all around all
over the world
and uh doing things we should not have
been doing bad bad things
we had a 50-year party we bought homes
and
cars and we mortgaged them and we put
them on credit cards and
we took out lines of credit we took out
big mortgages we built big
beautiful cities and then stopped giving
a [ __ ] about them and we we financed
this
uh with uh expansion
uh you know uh that was you know
financed by war
and deceit and fraud
and then we also you know did this on
the backs of
of immigrants that we pay slave labor to
and we did a lot of bad things and there
were good things that came with that
sure but we've had a party
we had a big party and the party was fun
and the music at the party was fun and
then
well now the music's not too fun at the
party anymore because everybody nobody
can sing anymore
you turn on the music and everybody's
like
help me help me and you go this isn't
this isn't that fun anymore
and you used to be able to turn on the
tv at the party and see some fun stuff
and chuckling
but you can't because you turn on the tv
and it chelsea handling like
you're white yeah so that's not fun
anymore either
and the party itself is starting to feel
not too
fun anymore but then there are people at
the party that are going
we can keep the party going if you come
into this
room and you go what's in this room and
you go well there's a million words you
can't say
and you can't look at each other and you
can't have any feelings thoughts or
expressions
and here's a little chip and we're
putting it in your ass and do you have
coronavirus
and put on your mask and don't speak and
if you have a business you can't run it
stand in the corner and look at the
[ __ ] floor and then and there's
other people that are going well we can
keep the party going too
but you got to come in this room and
what and i go what do you do in this
room
we just jump around without the music
and we can if you say there is no music
we kill you
we just say the party's going and it's
fun and then you go well if i point out
that the food sucks and there's no music
then we say no dummy did you read q
there isn't supposed to be music at this
party
music's the devil and you go what what
about food
you don't need any [ __ ] food q
provides you all the nutrition you need
you go
so i have a choice between one or two of
these rooms
or you could just sit in the living room
and wait for the parents
and you know who the parents are gonna
be president z
and china and when they open that
[ __ ] door
and they say we're here you're gonna say
mommy and daddy i love you
i'm so [ __ ] sorry i could have gotta
went in one of these rooms with the
crazy people
but i decided to sit here and stay
here and wait for you i'm so sorry the
kids from school brought people i didn't
know
and they started drinking and smoking
and throwing lamps
and they started buying houses and cars
and going to war
with other houses and i didn't consent
to any of that i just listened to music
i was just trying to get my dick sucked
in the closet i'm trans by the way
and then mommy and daddy we didn't know
we didn't know and then mommy and daddy
you're gonna say something in chinese
and then they're gonna zap you and
you're gonna fall to the floor
and they're gonna give you a social
credit score and you're gonna say well
it is what it is folks because the
party's
[ __ ] over
there are people who don't invite me to
things
and i'm always
i always don't know why i'm always
confused
as to why a lot of these hollywood
parties
hype house the sway house the tick tock
houses the content creators
don't really involve me and i want
i want because i want to be there with
them dancing as it all
goes down you know i want it to end i
want as it ends i want to be
because it's there's no more fitting way
to go than to just kind of
to rock out and to dance and to just
kind of enjoy yourself i mean
what are we supposed to do do do what
you can for the people in your life
make the change you can run for
something run for something local make
local change i'm not telling you to be a
cynical [ __ ] sit in your house and do
nothing
i'm telling you to stop every four years
invest in yourself
put your tits away amy schumer and
everybody else is taking your tits out
to you
here's here's my taint for voting like
what are we doing well what is this
i'm naked and so you should vote because
i'm naked
put your clothes on i don't understand
this
i mean i'm i'm just saying
that you should skip thanksgiving this
year because the threat of coronavirus
is real
that's all that's all i'm trying to say
here
you know start with the smoking
i've never smoked and i never will
but for those of you who are disgusting
and hopelessly addicted to nicotine
i'll tell you right now you have to get
into lucy it's a nick
it's a it's a company founded by caltech
scientists and former smokers looking
for a better and cleaner nicotine
alternative finally
tobacco alternatives that don't suck
researched and developed for three years
to be made for people not
patients they have three flavors it's a
gum
four milligrams of nicotine wintergreen
cinnamon pomegranate
it has a lozenge with four milligrams of
nicotine and cherry ice flavor nice
and it's convenient and discreet
products can be enjoyed anywhere on
flights at work on the go or even in the
gym
it's not a vape or an e-cigarette or a
pen or a problem
it's 20 20 you've got to get rid of the
cigs folks throw out the vape the dip
get some lucy nicotine gum or lozenges
this is the real deal
a subscription to lucy comes directly to
your door each month it's so simple you
don't have to leave your house because
lucy has the delivery
down if you're a tim dillinger listener
go to lucy.co
lucy.co and use promo code tim
you'll get 20 of all products including
gum or lozenges i'm telling you this
right now folks
if you want to get rid of the cigarettes
and you don't want to go into vaping
this is the perfect way to do it it
allows you to step down your nicotine
use
it's smart it's easier than cold turkey
cold turkey you're going to get fat
this is easy so you can do this a lot of
people are worried if i stop smoking
cigarettes i'm going to be a big horse
and it's true if you don't use something
like lucy
okay the product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco nicotine
is an addictive chemical i must read
that disclaimer
well we know where this product is
targeted towards people that are trying
to quit smoking
and they're not trying to substitute one
addiction for another nobody you're not
going to be addicted to lozenges
you're going to get rid of them you're
going to step down you're going to lose
use less and less
and then you're going to be done once
you break the physical that's the
hardest thing about smoking
the lighting of this thing i mean i want
one now the lighting of the cigarette
the the uh the indulgence the the whole
thing you know it's a ritual it's a
ritualistic behavior the smoke the
lighting the lighters the whole thing so
once you get rid of that a lot of your
addiction is gone
it's true once you go to the lozenges
okay
so i will say this you got to go to
lucy.co promo code tim
um sorry my voice doesn't even sound
good today
we gotta do it together okay let me take
let me take some
take some water
by the way i was we were just a dairy
queen and we had this mocha cookie fudge
we usually would go to dairy cream we
had three small blizzards and then try
them all
eat them all and try them all we eat
we got a pumpkin we got a mocha fudge
and we got uh
the strawberry chocolate covered
strawberry yeah now
that was the the best one the mocha
fudge yeah i want to comment it's like
everything that's coffee flavored now
just
assaults you with coffee everything
tastes like it has a shot of espresso in
it
haagen-dazs coffee ice cream is amazing
because it's a light [ __ ] touch
man if you wanted a cup of coffee you
won't have a cup of coffee other than
that give me a light [ __ ] touch
please give me something a little a
little bit more
subdued you don't have to throw a [ __ ]
you don't have to grind the coffee
bean down my throat which is what the
mocha fudge thing does it
it's too much it's too intensely coffee
we want a cafe latte feel a little
little cream a little milk in that [ __ ]
right yes or yes
okay ready are you ready uh rich
how did you [ __ ] that up i said are you
ready one two three
i'm not gonna do look at me we don't
have to do one two three
ridge wallet yum
and what we do there is we take the uh
the
the uh ruby two what is it applebees
red robin red rob such a difference
between all these uh
gourmet institutions red robin's slogan
is the slogan the american people
deserve yes
not even like hey we've got things it's
yum it's humming it's like it's like if
you're advertising a product to a dog or
a cat
red rubbing yum and you know what i hear
every time i hear that i could be wrong
this is why i hear red robin
you're fat yum
[Music]
you know what ridge wallet is i mean why
are we even doing this still they
emailed me the os money
ridge wallet is a [ __ ] metal wallet
i mean you know should i climb through
the [ __ ] screen
and and try to physically attack you in
your home
it is a front pocket wallet it is
minimal it is sleek
it comes in a lot of give me this
[ __ ] thing its ridge wallet dummies
we've done this for [ __ ] 10 years
here it is
you have a few credit cards that won't
show see
it's there's not a lot of room so you
got to pare down
simplify your life by putting it in
this little thing and you got a few
cards maybe your lawyer's number or
whatever you could fit some stuff and
you could fit five credit cards i mean
you could fit a lot you go a lot fatter
than that
you could go a lot fatter than this but
you don't need you don't want to
right and this is cool what is this one
what kind of metal is this
oh this one is the let's see here
i think this one is the uh titanium
you know what i like to do you put it
like this
brass knuckle
i mean you could it would hurt like how
it would hurt
what if you just did this and yeah you
mesh in someone's face
it's but here's what's so easy we don't
have sanitizer
but if you had sanitizer you just go
like this and you've sanitized your
entire wallet
instead of this big leather contraption
that isn't
you know this helps our show if you buy
the ridge while this helps our show
uh if we don't if they don't give us big
money next year i'm we're walking
because i i
quite frankly they've had enough i mean
they're great wallets they're great the
team has them
we just got dan one we got a good
backpack from them but this is the move
here you go to ridge.com
am and use the code t i am don't do it
without the go my father voted for them
without the code and i swear i was
looking at this [ __ ] boomer [ __ ]
during lunch and i said did you use the
promo code he goes no i forgot i said
you bought four
ridge wallets and didn't use my promo
code these people never stop [ __ ] you
your parents never stop destroying you
unless you let them
you must you i mean unless you make them
so here it is that's tough you hear that
it's a ridge wallet
it's a ridge one just breaks no this is
original i've had it for a year
it's this is a tough ass wallet yeah ben
drops [ __ ] all the time i drop [ __ ]
we're messy people it's
it's it's a great wallet so if you go to
ridge.com
tim tim link in the description put it
away
ridge.com slick in the description
uh you will you will get what do you get
here you get 10 off
will you pieces of [ __ ] just do this you
get 10
off and free worldwide shipping returns
am i wrong
so if you get free worldwide shipping
and returns you get 10 off i mean
am i wrong or is that a good [ __ ]
deal i feel like you have nothing to
lose
i don't think you have a goddamn thing
what's wrong if you don't like it yeah i
think you can send it back
and everybody loves it there's not one
person i've ever
seen that was upset about i did give it
to someone
who wasn't thrilled but it wasn't about
the wallet
because i gave it to them and then they
got necrotizing for shitis
and lost one leg and two arms
and the next time i saw them i tried to
like glass over that
and that is a flesh-eating bacterial
disease and they had that one like they
had
they had two arms and one leg on so they
just had the one leg
i think that was ready to go too and i
kind of glossed over it and i was like
how's the wallet they were like i don't
have [ __ ] i can't even find it i don't
have arms
you selfish [ __ ] so that was the only
complaint and i don't think it was about
the wallet it was just about the fact
that they
could no longer enjoy the product and i
inquired about it and they were
nasty to me
ridge.com tim tim thank you
we've got a lot of great guests coming
up i'm very excited some
secret guests coming up there going to
be a lot of
fun i'm really pumped
we're back out on the road tampa florida
palm beach
let's get the dates up baby
side splitters in tampa tuesday october
20th through the 21st wednesday west
palm beach florida october 22-24 that's
a weekend chicago illinois
october 27 to wednesday the 28th
oklahoma city
october 29th through the 31st kansas
city missouri november 10th
and 11th denver colorado november 12th
through saturday the 14th the last bit
of dates and then i'm hibernating slash
podcasting
for the winner a lot of great guests
coming up lot of fun
a lot of fun and a lot of enjoyable
times and moments that we will all
have together you can avoid your family
you can do a zoom if you want to do with
your family
it'll be a fun election we'll talk about
it i will have fun
we're going to have fun with it here
everybody else is gonna get mad they're
gonna tell you to vote i don't care who
you vote for
i don't care i don't care if you don't
vote i don't care
imagine caring imagine
care imagine being at lunch and
caring you're not going to take my life
that's the way i feel you're not going
to ruin my life
i'm on twitter i'm on all these things
you're not going to ruin my life
i don't care what you do i am a being
that's having a wild experience on the
planet
i wish that realization for you i wish
that realization for all of you out
there
that you're not subject to all this [ __ ]
it's not
real but uh quarantine you know we went
to new york to like you got a quarantine
and you got to fill out you know i put
the cat in the hat i
folded it up you fold it up like origami
you put it they have these things in a
suggestion box
you put your gives a [ __ ] cares
this state's too goddamn sloppy to be
fascist everyone's too
fat they can't put the
they can't find their gun it's stuck in
a roll of fat
it's it's gonna get bad but it won't get
bad for a while
it's pretty bad now but i mean real bad
i mean like can't leave your house bad
so enjoy the time you have left these
laws and [ __ ] you think you're it's it's
not
there's no teeth to many of them some of
them there is teeth too
and some of them are going to be worse
and if you can stop by all means if you
can stop people
if you can get us all of our freedoms
back i'm
i'd like that i'd love that
but up until that point i'm not going to
ruin and waste
i don't know how many hours days minutes
i have on this earth
none of us do how many tweets do you
want to read about amy coney barrett
how many how many tweets do you want to
read about
joe biden's crack addict son in the
ukraine
who's [ __ ] stealing money and smoking
crack and by the way
good for him he had fun
is he is he alive still or no yeah oh
hunter yeah yeah he's alive he's the
allah the
the one that didn't smell crack died
ain't that the way yeah
i just go off after i don't know how
much time
do you have any water is that water what
happens that's okay we don't i don't
need that i don't need it we're almost
done here
i just yell so much and then sometimes i
don't
but i get frustrated you know my aunt
sent me a pumpkin with an i voted
sticker on it's like will you grow up
i love her but come on you've only got a
few more listen we all
we might not have that many years of
going outside left
going outside left and you people are
talking about amy coney barrett
go swim while you can go hike while you
can go fish while you can
go [ __ ] while you can go enjoy the world
while you can go have dinner with
friends while you can i'm telling you
i'm not
i'm not even kidding it's not a joke
we're in a whole heap of [ __ ]
and if you don't want to enjoy whatever
time any of us have left on this [ __ ]
planet we could all get this disease
tomorrow and drop dead
they could send another 5g reboot of
this disease i'm not being a
conspiracy wacko i'm saying who the [ __ ]
knows what's the next
corona right corona what is it covet 19
what okova 20 might be the one right
that might be the one where you get it
and you fall down in the middle of the
[ __ ] street
so if you're driven to be an activist
god bless you
if you're faking it which you are relax
experience real friendship make a real
friend you know like dan who i [ __ ]
go on the road with who's
[ __ ] great dude who comes on the
patreon everybody on the patreon loses
their mind
because i'm not yelling for a whole hour
and i let a person make a human point
for a minute and then maybe i have a
friend and we're we're out there under
you know
we're trying to have a nice conversation
about it everybody's like maybe this guy
should kill himself
i yell every episode one at one episode
i take a minute
to say hey this is what's been going on
and
and you're like hey
where's the unfocused rage
here it is you got it here
but make a friend go through me and this
kid are doing stand-up comedy in a weird
[ __ ] world
traveling all over the place having a
lot of fun laughing our asses off
enjoying our [ __ ] lives we don't know
when they're ending we don't know but
we're gonna [ __ ] laugh our asses off
until they do
i wish that for a lot of people that
literally
get in touch with something spiritual
whatever the for me it's making people
laugh
for you i don't know what it is i don't
know what and i don't tell people it's
not the garyvee
experience i'm not going to tell you
what to do i'm not going to tell you
that
you know what spiritual start a vape
company or a hoodie
i don't know but if it is it is
but you're ruining and wasting your
[ __ ] lives every [ __ ] day you're
starting you're fighting you're fighting
with people in your family that you
you you might like if you didn't hate
each other for no reason
because you have different opinions on
nancy pelosi a woman who you've never
met
either side of your family has never met
her uh whether you love her hate her
she doesn't give a [ __ ] about you during
the remember she was giving a tour at
[ __ ] gelato
in her [ __ ] freezer and she lives in
san francisco that's basic [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay that's a foodie city and you're the
[ __ ] speaker of the [ __ ] house
why don't you get some real [ __ ] ice
cream in there okay you 119 year old
remember when a bird flew into her
georgetown [ __ ] townhouse and she had
to chase it around
that bird was trying to drag her back to
the dimension she belongs in
and somehow she fought off that burden
she's here showing us
[ __ ] salted caramel gelato while the
world [ __ ] burns
and you guys are fighting about her as
if she gives a [ __ ]
it's the wicked witch of the west is
that what they did in oz well actually
actually the flying monkeys are really
happy the benefit pack
what enough
with this children have some fun
when's the last time you people had any
goddamn fun
have a little bit of fun you know when i
used to be able to go to my my mother's
mental institution i would have
fun i would visit all the other mental
patients and talk to them
and then i started to realize that they
were actually right about the world
they'd be like everyone's trying to kill
you out there and i um
okay and then more recently i've gone
go on
you know i mean life life is not
supposed to be
an endless procession of of and yes
hey crap like this little guy that i
have with me danny goes he always goes
he goes
i want a great quality of life he says
it all the time ago this is what the
kids they go
i want a really good quality of life and
he's right but also
shut the [ __ ] up don't vocalize those
thoughts
just shut up create the quality of life
but that's what i would tell everybody
out there go out there
and get in some type of situation
universe world where you feel you're
being [ __ ]
you're excited about something because
dude people [ __ ] die
[ __ ] ends i hope this isn't my last
episode by the way this is
this is very like this is very strange
right it's very odd like and i just die
and this
first of all if it is it's brilliant but
i just don't want i don't want
i want to stay here because i just
started just started doing well after 11
years
i don't want to be too cryptic but i
will tell you this you got to enjoy
whatever you're [ __ ] doing you got to
enjoy the time you have you and don't
invest yourself in [ __ ] unless you
really are prepared
to do the work of investing yourself in
it you know
i remember during the bush gore election
711 was selling coffee cups
uh as to who you voted for yeah and i
went to my nanny and grandpa's house
and um my nanny was saying that they had
to stop doing that 7-eleven i had to
stop doing that because people were
throwing the hot coffee at each other
and we all laughed we all laughed that
because we said
what are you gonna do it was funny it
was funny that i mean now it's
you think they're selling those coffee
cups this year you think they're selling
trump biden coffee cups you think we
could ever get back to a
healthy democracy where you could sell a
hot
beverage in a cup that identifies who
you voted for
how scary is it that you can't do that
by the way
they they they could they could barely
do it in 2000 right
they could barely do it then but i'm
wondering
when we will ever get back to that place
where you could literally
you know sell here here's your 32 ounce
cup of hot liquid
with uh who you voted for on it be safe
go enjoy it go enjoy the land
i don't mean don't care about everything
i mean you're caring with the wrong
things
caring about the wrong things right
right look at these youtubers
they all made all this money by going
like
what are they review serials these
people they're trillionaires
because they're because that that's they
realize they're like smarter than all of
us
we're all trying to figure out the world
they're like i like apple tracks
that's the move
that's the move half of these youtubers
like i'm on a plane now
people are like i plans planes but
that's
it they're actually right
the tick tockers are actually right
that and maybe i've been in la for too
long but that's when you start
when you look at the the state of the
world
and you see a bunch of kids like
and i go oh they're right
that's what social media should be i'm
doing a dumb little dance
and not a 300 comment thread about trade
on facebook which you don't know
anything about you don't know what it
is that's when you know you're you're
crazy
you know that and crazy in in the true
sense of the word it's like
at a certain point you got to give it to
some of these youtubers who were just
like
the world is over it is fallen
and i just want to do things that will
pass the time for people
so they don't start militias and blow
each other's brains out
and that's that's the best version of
youtube are people who go
hey don't start a militia let's talk
about candy
don't join isis why because i'm gonna
give someone a lamborghini
okay that's the best version of that
i'm gonna open a gift don't kill your
wife
watch me open a gift you go oh good
hey don't put that cat in the microwave
there's pokemon cards here we're gonna
play a game
how many kids don't shoot up schools
because they get to watch david dobrik
give people lamborghinis
probably a lot so i'm not against any of
that i think it's good
it's just a wasting the time that's what
we have to do
we just have to run out the clock you
see
yeah yeah yeah it's running
we're just running at the clock we're
only here for a little while we're not
here forever
you're not gonna solve it you dumb [ __ ]
i think you're gonna solve it the
problems aren't even new
they've been around forever the problems
must be real
problems huh so we're just running out
the clock we're just trying to prevent
an incredible explosion of physical
violence that will bleed into every
aspect of american life
and what do we do and how do we do that
we we run out the clock with garbage
[ __ ]
i wish this stuff was a little better
i'd prefer a few more woody allen movies
a few thinkers
but the country doesn't want that so
it's okay what am i going to tell the
country what they want they want to
they want to watch it they want to watch
guy make it a table
guy making it to hey don't worry about
whose skull is what shape
watch me sand the table
we're running out the clock here
all the art you consume including maybe
even this
show is running out the clock
and it's important to do because if you
don't do it
the demons are going to win so to keep
the demons at bay
you do your little dance you do your
little
zoom thanksgiving you do your video for
this woman that just turned 80
because at a certain point you're gonna
hear
your parents car door shut and then
that's
it and you're gonna look around the
house and you're gonna go the party's
[ __ ] over
but at that time you don't want to look
around and say
[ __ ] this looked like a lot of fun and i
wish i had some of this fun
you want to say you know what the
party's over but i got that toothy blow
job
i threw up a lot of rum in the pool i
broke a lamp and blamed it on someone
else
and guess what i'll take my punishment
like a man
or a woman or a non-binary
entity good night